hums Gomez man it's put it back this is
three free games and fields the first
game is with a beer llama
so I never played this before I don't
know more than there's a llama in a beer
beer better be your bear now oh god what
happened what just happened okay so it's
a balanced game for [ __ ] sake what is
that what am i doing some instructions
please [ __ ]
oh there's arrow there's arrows what the
[ __ ] is that what is this no one told me
that flappy bird had a demon baby there
we go [ __ ] hell what is the point
there we go go you [ __ ] llama [ __ ] I
hate you so much stop I can't stop it
please
what is that who made this
the controls are [ __ ] out of control
get it why aren't you laughing then ha
look at okay look how I'm playing this
just look shut your [ __ ] mouth
look at this
[Music]
why do you do this
where are you going I just wanna break
this [ __ ] no more no more llama
no more lava great Lama great times
[ __ ] that second game a [ __ ]
okay what happened what happened little
screen God did what is happening what
the [ __ ] up for round two
what the [ __ ]
alright let's let's play it um oh my god
you never know what's gonna happen in
these games its cat oh god Kyle didn't
want to play with me what a shame
[ __ ] Kyle if you doesn't want to play
well Kyle can go and suck on his mom
tits but I can play with you right how
do you knew that okay how does he know
my name fine we can play not perfect act
one oh I'm a fine girl is that what this
game is about it jumped through the
circle whoa
the graphics in this game is amazing
whoa oh man what the [ __ ] no stasis what
fangirls are [ __ ] terrifying
[Music]
I never been to stay in him in late why
is she peeking like that what is that
kinder kinder fart no Kin Kin dan fair
whoa
well this is sauna character I've never
seen her I like the design of this map
though whoa
gotta go stuff paste gotta go so gotta
go gotta go show
Sally pours no all she wanted was to do
is go fast what the [ __ ] is that
another sonic girl I guess sonic the
squirrel let's see how she dies AK 9
doesn't have a name though
Sonic is like scissor me girl
come here sesame girl scissor McGarrett
ah I can see myself but very faintly no
it's getting dear kid it's getting
decade Oh No Sally Sally
oh it's getting knocked darker how do I
jump what am i [ __ ] might supposed to
do this is the end bros this is the end
I'll see you on the flip side
PewDiePie signing out oh [ __ ] me Sonic
[Music]
game over at question mark I don't know
please please let it be I can't quit it
and it's over thank God oh my god Hey
okay insane oh my god alright one more
game race how can we possibly top that
how last but not least we have probably
the greatest game of all time for a core
it's a cat I'm a cat look at me I'm a
cat and I can do parkour apparently I
don't know let's check not very good at
parkour oh that's my core if that's not
my core I don't know what parkour is
wants to cook oh my god did I what I
want physics I'm pretty sure if you're a
cat you don't have to abide to the laws
of physics Isaac Newton said that I
think it [ __ ] what is this
get off alright let's check the controls
alright here we go
I'm a kitty cat and I've gained
saint-saëns in that game same things Oh
having some wine are we having some wine
up not anymore
[ __ ] they don't even break come on
I throw quite a punch though what who's
next lives like this but who does that
who thought that was a good night you're
asking me to do this you're asking it
you - why'd you did it - didn't you what
the [ __ ] was that
what what was that
alright I'm collecting kiddy coins
because why not
amazing all right listen I'm bored let's
go check upstairs
this is how cats walk up stairs by the
way everyone knows this [ __ ] any Chad
can jump up in the sofa why can't I why
cat I [ __ ]
what is that jump who invented that
there we go alright we're up here [ __ ]
you get off my way don't you know who I
am I am serpents I am sir PPT TV really
Arabic sense it's good PD how is that
glass doing that that glass is a wizard
I swear I know because I've seen quite a
few wizards in my days this game has
been amazing all these games are free
for you bros for life sure I found this
so you can check them out yourself if
you would like thank you for leaving
like on this episode I really appreciate
that's very awesome of you and thank you
for being a bro here's some brofist for
you bros